oh is this what you were very particular
about your clothes yes I am yeah and not
just the fashion Sensibility it goes far
beyond fashion tell us what you mean by
that well you know you have to dress so
you can make a quick getaway right you
know you don't know who's after you
you know you might have to run somewhere
right so I you know I try to as much as
I can dress appropriately appropriately
so that you can sleep I can you can flee
at any moment so that means no high
heels yeah just in you know right now I
wear heels but like in life you know
flat shoes watch your bag that's
strapped across you know what is he a
dial boiling what is it like run a look
that we're both doing this yeah what is
it you think who's coming after you what
I don't know but it could happen it
could happen
you just never know you know if you need
to get you know it might just be that
you need to get somewhere quickly
are you the kind of person who when you
enter a situation like a room you case
it out a little bit as you're you know
to me in like is there a window could I
is that real could I swim away yeah
where were the exits you look for that
kind of thing yeah I'm just generally a
prepared person you know I have an
earthquake do you have an earthquake I
do have an earthquake it yeah that that
was a tent a tent yeah no my plan is to
take over someone else's house I don't
believe you have a tent to Andy do you
have an earthquake kit and a tent and
the whole thing sorta I fear will sift
through the wreckage to get what we need
Jordan I've buried a lot of wine
and just that's what I intend to do I'm
gonna be the guy wandering around just
completely trashed you have good bearing
places for them or do are they are they
well not telling you exactly on your
property are the one who try to find my
one stash
they're under the sign that says wine
here careful when digging three feet
deep what I want to mention you you have
two new dogs is that right I do yeah
what are you what kind of dogs you have
they are mutts they're from the shelter
you rescued and that's terrific
that's great we actually bury things
they try to bury things they fancy a
toaster yeah they Phantom dig though
they'll be like they'll like phantom dig
in the bed like thinking that there's
dirt there but there's nothing happening
that means they've gone insane like
little mines they're like then they do
this then they walk against the wind
yeah and did you ever have any follow me
around everywhere you know they like me
are they here now this is it do they
ever follow you and ever follow you in a
car yeah they do
that's why you're paranoid we just
figured out why I think that dogs
following you I did actually take
pictures of them the other day they were
outside looking at me through the door
like just sitting there yeah like
looking at me and I was like they're
stalking yeah
they mate sometimes you get a phone call
and you're like that's four click